Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new hope Marvel phase 4
video Mark Ruffalo did a comic-con panel last
week where he announced a bunch of
Marvel phase 4 plans and projects for
the Hulk character confirming some of
our theories and a few things I totally
wasn't expecting so we'll break it all
down we're doing that big infinity saga
box set giveaway for all the blu-rays
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your theories
about Hulk during Marvel phase 4 on the
video we'll just break this down top 5
style starting with number 5 Mark
Ruffalo confirmed he's sticking around
for the long term in the MCU his
original Marvel movie contract still has
one movie left on it before he needs to
renegotiate based on all the stuff that
he said he's doing is the Hulk during
Marvel phase 4 it sounds like he will
have to sign a new contract to continue
being the Bruce Banner hold for Marvel
so I'll explain what all the new
confirmed Hulk projects are in just a
second interestingly enough though he
did make it seem like he won't be a big
character again during Thor for love and
thunder among those projects even though
some of the movie will take place on
earth because new Asgard is still in
Norway right now there's based on the
way he was talking about it I'm not
expecting Hulk to show up for anything
more than a very short cameo if anything
which I'm totally cool with they're
still working on locking down Christian
Bale as the main villain of that movie
there's the promise of beta ray bill
finally debuting in a really big way in
the MCU Kevin Feige revealed that he was
a character during Thor Ragnarok that
they ended up cutting out late in the
process so apparently there's a whole
bunch of deleted scenes of beta ray bill
in thor ragnarok you also have the Loki
that's totally messing with the time
various Authority in all these previews
of the Loki series so they already have
plenty of characters to handle during
Thor for love and thunder number 4 the
Marvel phase 4 movies and series that
Mark Ruffalo confirmed that he's
appearing in just going in order that
they're going to be released starting
with Marvel's what-if series he's
confirmed four episodes of that he
didn't say how many episodes but the
first season of 10 episodes will be
released in summer 2021 right after
Doctor Strange to multiverse of madness
he didn't say if his Hulk episode will
be for what if Incredible Hulk or for
another episode because Kevin Feige said
they were doing a what-if episode for
every single Marvel movie from the
saga which is 23 episodes total
including the first two spider-man
movies spider-man homecoming in
spider-man far from home spider-man on
the Disney Plus series gets a little
complicated with what they're allowed to
do with the Sony Marvel sharing deal and
Tom Holland so don't worry about that
too much right now this is mostly a hulk
video then the hulk is confirmed to be
appearing in the marvel she-hulk Disney
Plus series I think we all kind of
assumed he would he just confirmed it
during this panel the series is only
going to be six episodes so Mark Ruffalo
didn't say how many episodes he'd be in
I think the idea is they're figuring
that out right now because they don't
start shooting till later this year they
haven't officially cast their she-hulk
yet but apparently they're looking for a
comedic actress like Alison Brie who can
do both the comedy and the Hulk stuff
like the hardcore Hulk stuff but did you
go well I'd like to play the she-hulk
and then I made some phone calls so
that's why the internet thinks that
Alison Brie is she Hulk she did the
gloww wrestling series on Netflix but
we'll find out who she Hulk is by
comic-con this summer
number three next Mark Ruffalo said that
he had pitched a new hoax solo series on
Disney plus he said the plot of his Hawk
series would be very similar at least in
themes to the original Incredible Hulk
TV series in the 1970s with Bill Bixby
and Lou Ferrigno's Hulk there's a big
Stanley Easter egg in this too if you
guys didn't know obviously Stan Lee
famous for all of his cameos and all the
different Marvel projects all across the
films but his very first cameo and live
action was on the Incredible Hulk 1978
TV series Mark Ruffalo said the basic
premise of his Incredible Hulk TV series
would just be his version of Professor
Hulk after the events of Avengers
endgame in 2023 on the run again being
chased down by Thunderbolt Ross and the
government there is word of them doing a
lot of Thunderbolts stuff during Marvel
phase four so an easy solution would be
to have Thunderbolt Ross be the main
villain to that series and just have it
be Hulk vs the Thunderbolts with all the
biggest Marvel villains teaming up
trying to capture the whole four six
episodes love the concepts just want to
see some more badass Hulk stuff
happening during Marvel phase four which
it sounds like they do have plans for
number two this is actually probably the
most exciting thing is that Mark Ruffalo
said that he's pitching Kevin Feige on a
new Hulk vs. Wolverine
movie Headey confirmed that there was
still kind of a rights issue with
universal so that's why there's no
official date for any kind of new Hulk
movie even though they're trying to work
on one but if there was any confusion
Mark Ruffalo is really excited to do a
Hulk vs. Wolverine movie it's more a
question of when they can get to that
story
worst case scenario they just have to
thor ragnarok it into some other larger
movie with a couple other Avengers
characters in the background the weird
technicality of the rights issue is that
they can do whatever they want to with
Hulk in other people's movies they just
can't put Hulk in the title of the movie
and arguably if you're going to do Hulk vs.
Wolverine you want to put that in the
title here's the thing though Wolverine
just feels like too big of a character
for them to debut a new version on a
Disney Plus series first because they
can do Hulk TV shows like he said
Incredible Hulk solo series that he's
pitching I think it's more reasonable
for them to introduce the concept of the
Weapon X program using the Thunderbolt
Ross character in the Disney Plus series
just in the background you just find out
that that's been happening this whole
time in fun fact the Weapon X program is
actually just the most recent iteration
of the Super Soldier program that
started with Captain America so
Wolverine technically isn't Weapon X
he's Weapon 10 as in Roman numeral X
Captain America is designation weapon
one so don't be surprised if they try to
use some MCU Captain America super
soldier mythology when they introduce a
new version of the Weapon X program into
the MCU in Thunderbolt Ross already had
a version of the Super Soldier Serum in
the Incredible Hulk movie there was even
a scene where he explained a
quote-unquote special program that
sounded exactly like the Weapon X
program this is that scene.
You're aware that we've
got an infantry weapons
development program. Well in ww2 they
initiated a subprogram
for biotech force enhacement.
Yeah, Super Soldier.
Yes.
An oversimplification. But yes.
And I dusted it off.
Got 'em doing serious work again. Bold work.
Banner's work was very early phase.
He thought he was working on radiation
resistance.
I would never have told him what the project really was...
That was 2008, when they
didn't have any of
the x-men rights and couldn't do big
x-men Easter eggs but doesn't it sound
like they were writing that as if
Thunderbolt Ross was conducting the
Weapon X program and this was just part
of that now that they have all the
rights to the x-men characters there are
no limitations they can reference
anything that they want Mark Ruffalo
also said that he pitched a different
professor Hulk movie to Marvel this one
was more about the Hulk and banner
battling it out for control of his body
remember the Avengers infinity saga a
deleted scene from infinity war where we
saw a version that play out during the
big final battle of Wakanda it would be
a whole movie for something like that
which does sound cool I posted that
whole deleted scene to my channel a
while ago so I'll link it at the end of
this but he didn't give any kind of
indication as to who the main villain of
that movie would be besides Hulk and
banner just fighting each other but a
lot of you have seen the Thunderbolt
Ross Red Hulk rumors if they really do
start setting that character up after
the Black Widow movie during Marvel
phase four or Disney Plus series Red
Hulk is a great villain for a Hulk movie
easy slam dunk in because Mark Ruffalo
intends on coming back during Avengers 5
in three to four years whenever they get
to that movie there's always potential
for a Dark Avengers subplot in Marvel
phase 5 too but number one of course Red
Hulk during Marvel phase four in
Avengers 5 what we know right now is
that he's rumored to appear at some
point during the she-hulk series which
might sound strange at first but if they
have the rights to do whatever kind of
Hulk TV show that they want it would
make sense that they tease a lot of Hulk
based characters on the TV shows right
now there's no Thunderbolts movie that's
happening during Marvel phase four but
there is a good chance that after the
current batch of marble Disney Plus
series the next two years they'll
announce a thunderbolt series and that's
where you see them do a lot of Red Hulk
stuff short answer is there's a lot more
Hulk characters coming during Marvel
phase four also Falcon and Winter
Soldier is supposed to set up some
under bold stuff and that's going to be the
very first Disney Plus series coming in
August right now the she-hulk expected
release date is fall winter 2021
sometime between October and December
unless there's some big delay that's
also when they're supposed to release
the Hawkeye series and I'm not sure when
they're intending on releasing the moon
night series but I will do videos for
all that stuff when we get more
information let me know in the comments
if Marvel still has trouble doing a hoax
solo movie in a couple years how do you
want them to handle Hulk vs. Wolverine
sidenote really cool HBO News they just
released a teaser revealing the HBO is
working on a bunch of hardcore series
based on major PlayStation games
that's right PlayStation TV series The
Last of Us is going to be the first one to
get a TV series so I'll do a teaser
video for that soon I've got my fingers
crossed that they're also working on a
God of War TV series that would be
amazing
HBO God of War but everyone click here
for that Avengers infinity saga deleted
scene with the Hulk and click here for
that brand-new first look at the Batman
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!